this is a production of Cornell
University
we are seconds
school of science graduates recently and
we're really excited to have this many
folks here to help us celebrate today my
name is Chris smart and I am the
director of the school of integrated
plant science here at Cornell I am also
a scientist and I actually studied
diseases of vegetables that
[Music]
[Applause]
passion your hard work and your
dedication some well-known to their
magnitude or here with us today you have
been amazing mentors and incredible
teachers so we to the faculty have
supported the students throughout their
graduate degree you graduate degree is a
really difficult thing to do the
students know that the Writing Center
that and I love that the families known
as wise thank you and finally today we
will be celebrating graduation and
including five different graduate fields
and so I think it's very important that
we think our directors of Graduate
Studies our graduate field
and in particular elusive as well so
before we begin to celebrate each I
graduate individually this is my
opportunity I have a captive audience so
I get to say a few words as those
students and then we well I usually
start with those boarding announcement I
would like to I would hope that the
students can remember two things as
Uniqua now the first is to use your
network and the second is to use your
voice to convocation at 12:30 you will
ever Bill Nye the Science Guy speak
about both of these things much more
effectively then I will speak about them
now
and yet I persist so I think the network
is something that makes you
think about and a lot of people don't
think about until you really need
something I've had the pleasure of
talking with many of you over the last
one to six years and it has come to my
attention that right many of you feel as
though perhaps you don't deserve to be
where you want my follow many of you on
Twitter and I follow students on Twitter
cool around the world and a common theme
among students giving their masters or
PhD is what's called the impostor
syndrome because Dukes feel as though
they don't deserve to be getting the
degree that they have and that someone
will find out and like you know tell bro
oh they're an imposter they're not as
smart as they say that they are so this
may not mean anything to you but none of
you are frogs
not one of you you are not a Koster's
you have been trained by the best
faculty in the world in the plant
sciences and you have a network that you
can use you're gonna be scared and
there's others are and all of a sudden
there's gonna be things that
Wow I don't know I'm going to deal with
this well one of the things you could do
is even on your mentor say hey did you
have to deal with this can you help me
out and you know times out of 10 they're
gonna say yeah I done with that here's
what I did make it work to make me do
the network that you have is an amazing
group of passionate and smart people not
just a faculty but you as cohort I think
use a cohort are really important in
being network for each other in your
success is not driven quite a success of
someone else
the goal is for all of you to be
incredibly successful so don't compare
yourself to another compare cohort in
the success that you have the second
thing that I want to talk about
capisci was when I became the director
of the school of Hebron plant science I
did not have any administrative position
before so I started attending meetings
that I wasn't really sure I belong that
and for a while this may come as a shock
to many of you and grow
and then I realized and so our people
come you know you're invited to an uber
music I'll just invite you to a meeting
to see your city be fabulous to meet you
for a reason it's because you have like
a deep skill set that can impact
something to that group you need to
remember that your voice is as important
to all of the people in that group
whether is a group of educators or a
group of academics or a group of
policymakers or a group from industry
that you're interacting with your voice
at that table is critical please don't
forget to use it and another place where
I think your voice is equally critical
is when you're talking to your friends
and family and to the public
many of you know that I'm extremely
passionate about public engagement and
engaging the public in science Warren
friends and colleagues will be in the
plants for any professor
we're not but it's almost never
I am scientist national scientists
that's a really great thing people when
you're at the party oh you just graduate
what do you do I'm a scientist and I
study this because in 2018 the survey
was done 1,000 Americans and of that
hundred thousand Americans 81% could
leave living scientist not name the live
expenses so ninety nineteen percent that
one thousand people became a scientist
but far more than 19 percent of our
population so certainly all of those
people many of those people had met a
scientist but they still associate us as
being scientists
to enable people to understand why we
study science why it's important and how
it affects their lives because as we
know there are really really serious
problems that you guys are gonna have to
beware and you're gonna need to use your
network and your voice to help us solve
these folks those are my two things
[Applause]
[Music]
I have done some research and I said we
have some academic regalia and academic
regalia goes back to the earliest
universities in Europe and depending on
the source that when people left the
university they would wear their
academic regalia and there is some Lord
that when they were in town those people
like it won't respect because people
knew they were professors at a
university and actually read read from a
colleague in the UK saying that there is
a law that if people wore their academic
regalia in China to a bar there like a
bunch of beer
so the idea comes in different colors
mine is green because I graduated from
Michigan State University or Chevron's
on this please indicate your degree so
PhD green Chevron's and masters will
have to the color colors would also
depends on the university that you went
to and you'll see that the Victorian
faculty have foods that are bright blue
at Michigan State University actually
indicates the college or the university
from which to graduate so I graduated
from the College of Agriculture and so
mine is thanks
and if you look on the inside of the
book the colors on the inside of the
hood indicate the colors of the
University so hopefully all the
graduates are red and white because
Cornell colors are red like Michigan
State's colors are green and white and
so mine will be green and white and as
you see on the faculty that are wearing
their regalia from their University you
might see many different colors and this
also varies depending on the country so
we will call up the chair of the section
and the director of Graduate Studies
from each of the five fields
[Applause]
and your major advisor your major
advisor you'll hand your foot to your
major advisor your major advisor will
take the hood over your head indicating
the passage of knowledge from one
generation to the next
your name will be on your mind for an
excellent photo-op some family members
feel free to stand up particular there
we take
[Applause]
so starting us up is the Graduate fuel
in horticulture the chair of the section
Steve Greiner will be reading the names
director of Graduate Studies Bill Miller
will be handing out certificates
[Music]
[Music]
is coming for agriculture
[Applause]
for extra budget creating more diversity
quality piece of advisors
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
our next graduate is Dylan Toback the
only his master's in this thesis for
optimizing green house tomato production
responses to supplemental
[Applause]
Dillons and Ison was not reading
announcer our next graduate is the right
lender her master's in working with
thesis topic the use of black polygon
landmarks to advance reduced system
beats
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
next graduate is lord lorik Lords
dissertation is uncovering genes
controlling tree architecture and
quality
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
propagation
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so the next
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kesava
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
next is Dianna soiree Tommy PhD with dr.
Margaret Smith his title was genetics of
multiple disease resistance in maize and
red and science communication
[Applause]
tear Easter eggs each without repentance
a dissertation title is micro and macro
views of me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Adam is actually attending his own son's
graduation today so dr. smart is
probably in that pool today our first
recipient here America fell intended for
PHP a stupid with dr. Michelle hack and
her dissertation of searching for the
missing links connecting Kokoro virus
structural biology to functions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Elizabeth silhouettes with mark whoops
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Michael alter a PhD in my laboratory
Michael's dissertation user in her mini
era at the intersection of wheat and
wildcraft communities
[Applause]
he's learning PhD with dr. Sarah Peppa
French
Adrian's thesis was quantifying disease
risk for the northern rooftop nematode
boy to guide apple in potato and New
York State
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rich population biology of Roma binky
and management strategies for formerly
father
Angela Cruz dr. Michele had a roadmap to
control one one big issue specific
molecular analysis of the vector
pathogen interface
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
disease resistance from s like aversive
twenties against raised one strings of
suitableness cerini at the bar tomato
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Arisa Oscar better
dude with market groups for PhD
dissertation characterization of symptom
development of symptom determinant of
grapevine and the virus by reverse
genetics and proteomics
[Applause]
Sarah more PHP molecular epidemiology
and host range dignify us why
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I yield the floor to Tony 15 Tomaso
chair of science
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
includes our graduates and the
individual recognition I thought I
explained a bit what happens next first
of all Alisha has cookies in the cold
water
right next door so please do that for
those of you that will be going to the
official University hooding ceremony
that begins at 5:00 p.m.
just walk away I think the students in
the faculty are to line up at 4:30 so we
have plenty of time and actually just
say that the event there is you'll see
very different from the image here we
like the relaxed atmosphere where
very engaged ear theory will be putted
by the Dean of the Graduate School
barber news and the about probably a
hundred to a hundred and fifty graduated
PS PhDs walked across the stage in about
an hour so it goes very quickly but I
hope you can join us there and tomorrow
after the ceremony initial huff stadiums
for those of you will be going all of
the undergraduates and the Agricultural
Sciences major the plant sciences major
and all of our graduate degree
recipients today are invited to a free
lunch for you and your entire family at
the trillion which is right next door
we'll have sandwiches and things for you
to eat because it's probably gonna be a
little warm and I guess in your
[Music]
again congratulate all apprentice
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu